I'm Steven manda Jones I'm a gameplay
designer at 2k Australia I'm Anthony
Burch I'm a writer gearbox and we're
gonna talk about Athena while you watch
gameplay of Athena in warrens breezy
cool cool so we'll jump into Athena's
skill trees here so first up we've got
her action skill which is called kinetic
aspis basically it's her thinnest
personal shield and when she activates
it she pulls up her shield and she can
prevent all incoming damage from a
frontal direction and it's not only that
the shield will store that incoming
damage and she can then throw it out
into her enemies and deal double that
damage back to them that sounds
incredible tell me more about the
individual skill trees yeah sure so
first up we've got the phalanx tree
which is heavily focused on the action
skill the aspis and buffing that up and
giving it additional effects for example
she can change it so that it will absorb
incoming elemental damage types with the
prismatic age of skill here so if it's
damaged by fire damage or shock damage
it will then deal that type back when
she throws it out which is really cool
that's electrifying Steven there's also
some really good co-op buffs in the
skill tree so if you're playing with
friends you've got nice ways to sort of
protect your friends heal them pull them
out of fight for your life or draw aggro
from the enemies back onto Athena
so if you're playing like with a partner
or in a group this is a really good
skill tree for that the capstone skill
of this one is also really cool it's
called wrath of the goddess here it
basically allows the aspis to jump to
additional enemies when she throws it so
like if you've filled it right up with a
ton of energy you can just wipe out a
whole room of dudes with that one it's
super cool
so that tree was about playing with
friends what if I am alone in life well
it's that skill tree will still work for
you if you're alone in life that's
amazing but moving on we've got the
zyphus skill tree here which is focused
on her close combat weapon which is her
sword called zyphus it's an energy sword
so this skill tree is filled with lots
of melee buffs and high mobility things
and one of the key features of this
skill tree is with the REM skill on the
third tier here she unlocks any status
effect for herself which is a bleed so
her melee attacks will cause enemies to
bleed over time and then moving on from
that she has skills like bloodlust on
the next tier which will help her
regenerate health as she makes people
bleed
so as she spreads her bleeds around the
battlefield she gets stronger and
stronger and can keep going and as we
get down to a capstone skill here which
is called blood rush it basically
converts a melee attack into like a
dashing strike so that helps her get
those bleeds going on their targets and
the cool thing about this skill is if it
hits a target that isn't bleeding or
kills someone the cooldown it has is
immediately reset so you can sort of
chain it between a bunch of enemies and
just get them all bleeding at once which
is really cool that was an interesting
screen to go to Chris tell us more about
the final skill tree Steven sure we've
got the surrounding storm skill tree
here which is a elemental skill tree
it's mainly focused on fire and shock
damage it makes use of electrifying
Steven it's electrifying and inflaming a
lot is what you meant to say yeah that's
a good one is this way you're a writer
it makes use of a stacking mechanic
using a maelstrom which as you deal far
in shock damage you generate Maelstrom
stacks which increase your elemental
damage output and these stacks
constantly decay over time but that rate
of decay increases as you build up more
so basically you get these big spikes of
power as you generate your stacks you
have a lot of other skills such as smite
which add extra fire and shock attacks
into your arsenal
this one is cool because when you're
airborne you can hit enemies with this
fire and shock damage from above and
since we've got low gravity like it's
really easy to trigger that off because
you can easily spend a lot of time there
Zeus is rage is a pretty cool one as
well it's modification to the aspis so
when she throws it out it spawns a fire
and lightning storm at the target
location dealing like constant damage to
anyone it hits and the cool thing about
that is it'll generate you a ton of
Maelstrom stacks as well so it sort of
snowballs you into all this extra damage
if you have the cool skills here as well
like a capstone here Hades chuckles it
modifies her slam attack so that any
enemies damaged by it she tethers
herself to them with like a lightning
tether and if she keeps that tether
without breaking it until the end of the
duration any tethered enemies released a
fire Nova which hurts more people
generates more Maelstrom stacks
achieving its bonus Maelstrom stacks on
top of that so you really want to make
use of your slam and hit as many people
as you can and really get a big spike in
your mail stream stacks from that one I
might like to see that skill cool well I
think we could pick that up that's not
how you spend skill points you big dumb
idiot there you go or what you're
noticing there is the slightly irregular
layout here in the first tier we've got
four points and then one because it
basically makes the Maelstrom skill
compulsory to advance further down the
tree kind of similar to what players
would have seen with the necromancers
ordered chaos tree and bottle ends to
just grab a few other skills to go with
it
looks like we're ready to go
[Music]